this building site is creating anxiety
in many parts of Assam state the workers
are constructing a detention camp
there'll be space for some 3,000 inmates
it's not yet clear exactly who will be
sent here but close to 2 million as some
residents are at risk of being
incarcerated in camps like this one
because their names were excluded from a
list of so called verified citizens
published by the government in August in
a strange twist some of the construction
workers building the camp fear they
themselves may end up imprisoned here
I've been working at the site for six
months I was scared when I found my name
was not on the list I hope everything
will be okay what can I do
the list is causing distress among many
communities in a some a state of some 33
million people those left off the list
are being asked to produce documents
proving that their family has lived
there for a certain length of time or
face being stripped of their citizenship
critics say the measure targets Bengali
speaking Muslims many of whom came from
the neighboring Indian state of West
Bengal the government denies the claim
but this offers little comfort for those
who fear losing everything we have not
any connection with foreign countries
like Bangladesh or Pakistan we are brown
and but up here and our names are not
included in this list so we are very
scared we are scared of our own future
and our own children's this camp is just
one of six that's being built by the
government in Assam it's due to be
operational by next year then it will
become clear who the local authorities
have decided to inter and as has been
suggested by some politicians whether
such camps will also be built in other
Indian states
joining us to talk more about this is
dwz misha Jaiswal Nimisha this seems
outrageous how are people across the
country taking this valve Melissa
surprisingly there have not really been
any mass protests or movements across
the rest of India about this National
Register of citizens partly this might
have to do with the fact that what may
be considered mainland and JA does not
concern itself with local to a local
level politics in the northeastern
states which are geographically removed
and this also might have to do with the
fact that the government at the center
the BJP has simply painted out this
exercise as a way to respond to local
Assamese demands to weed out illegal
immigrants illegal Bangladeshi
immigrants so people in the rest of
India might feel illegal immigrants
should be weeded out that sounds about
fair and the ruling BJP is actually a
very popular party which also might
explain why most of the country does not
seem to be bothered by the NRC now the
report mentioned that most of the people
likely to be impacted are Muslims so why
is this happening and why is this
happening now fabulous that's important
to understand that this is a brand of
Assamese sub nationalism which has been
running for decades the demand for the
NRC has been running for decades the
people of Assam the ethnic original
people of Assam believed that their
demographics have been affected by
illegal immigration from Bangladesh
specially fuelled by the wall for
Bangladeshi liberation in 1971 now if
you ask the people demanding the NRC
they do not discriminate between Hindus
or Muslims they also want Hindu
Bangladeshis to be weeded out but
however another law passed by this
current government at the centre by the
BJP government actually allows any
Hindus who might have been left off of
the NRC to be included simply by the
fact that they are Hindus that they are
minorities in Bangladesh which basically
means that the people who will be left
out at the end will be Muslim so this
belief of the critics
this is a charter this is a citizenship
register that targets Muslim may well be
true very quickly how likely will these
people be put in detention camps I mean
we saw them being built but it hasn't
happened yet
well again so there's a lot of guesswork
happening here at detention camps are an
option if an agreement is worked out
with Bangladesh repatriation is an
option we're also sharing of work
permits so right now no clear picture
about what exactly will happen you Misha
guys well thank you